if my son came home from school one day
and said to me look mum I'll be honest
with you I I think I'm gay I would take
it honest
what if you're what if your son came
home and said I think I'm black
[Music]
well I mean obviously I would I mean
obviously I'd have to see him down and
be like so you don't think if he thought
he was the opposite gender you might you
just sit him down and tell him that he's
well that's what I said I mean I would
listen to him sit him down and have a
conversation with him but this all comes
down to the way that you raise your
children but you you said they have
their own mind so why doesn't he make up
his own decision why would you have to
sit him down
what do you mean sorry because you said
you said they have their own mind yes
and they can they're making their own
decision but I can still have an input
and I can still talk about so if you
wanted to change his gender you'd let
him
no of course not